independence is not a distraction
from the task of post-covered
reconstruction
it is essential to getting that right
of course we won't wait to be
independent to start doing
the right things now i'm about to give
you concrete examples of how
even in areas that are still
substantially reserved to westminster
the scottish government is nevertheless
acting now
to rebuild and renew and as i
do so ask yourself this if this is what
we can do with
limited powers how much more could we
achieve
if we didn't have one hand tied behind
our backs
take social security the pandemic has
reinforced as never before the necessity
of strong
social protection that will be there for
all of us
in times of need for many people in
scotland the post-war welfare state has
been a reason to support the union
but both the values and the practical
measures that
underpin that system are being
dismantled by westminster governments we
don't vote for
when the pandemic hit the uk had one of
the lowest levels of statutory sick pay
in the whole of europe it still does
brutal cuts to welfare have forced
families into poverty
and taking hundreds even thousands of
pounds a year
out of the pockets of those who can
least afford it
westminster has given us the bedroom tax
benefit sanctions
the two child cap and the abhorrent rape
clause
and the rhetoric has sought to divide
and stigmatize
we take a different approach on saturday
john swinney made the truly landmark
commitment
that if we are re-elected next may
lunches and breakfasts will be available
free of charge
all year round for every primary school
child in scotland
this alongside the baby box and the
doubling of early years education
is part of our commitment to making
scotland the best place in the world to
grow up
at the heart of that commitment is the
new scottish child payment
we will shortly become the only part of
the uk
to give low-income families an extra 10
pounds a week for
every child initially for children up to
age 6
and then for every child up to age 16.
this has been described as a game
changer in the fight to end
child poverty the first payments will be
made
in february but i know that for families
struggling now february is still a long
way off
so i am announcing today a 100 million
pounds package
to bridge that gap and help others
struggling most with the impact of covet
over the winter months it